talking uh
currently assistant any other programs
um thank you very much for your
introduction and thank you very much for
the invitation uh to speak here at this
Workshop
um so my name is I'm currently a
research fellow
um and today I'll be talking about uh
distributed graph techniques in the MPC
model
um and I'll specifically Define the MPC
model that I'll be talking about
um and just as a quick disclaimer
um I tried getting a crash course on a
database Theory by asking chai gbt give
me a press course
um but unfortunately I still lack a lot
of knowledge so I apologize ahead of
time
um if I don't quite understand your
database Theory questions in terms of
queries hopefully some members of the
audience can translate these questions
to me um in breast theoretic terms
so um let me start with the definition
of the MPC model that iol specifically
be talking about in terms of graphs
um so you'll see that this is um a
somewhat different model that what uh
Paris and Xiao talked about in their
presentation
um but I'll discuss the similarities and
the differences between these two models
so the mpsc model that I'll be talking
about
um for my presentation consists of M
machines
um and unlike the database model we're
considering synchronous rounds so we
often have algorithms that take o of log
log and rounds so not just one round two
rounds
um so we're considering synchronous
right now model we also have synchronous
rounds
above your one round algorithms can
yeah
synchronous yeah we generally don't
really talk about one random algorithms
in our settings right so we have we have
M machines here
um and when you're given some graph you
partition the edges among the machines
um and the edges are partitioned
arbitrarily so for each of the machines
uh the each individually has some s
space so s is an important parameter for
us
and each of the machines can perform
some local computation
after they compute the computation they
can talk to each other via rounds of
communication
so the total space you can calculate to
be M times s
but specifically the complexity measure
that we care about for this model here
uh is the total space that we use uh the
space per machine and the number of
rounds of communication
so you are also ignoring the time taken
by each machine we're not considering
the time taken by each machine most of
our algorithms are near linear time but
for this for this model we're not
considering an amount of time each
Mission takes
yeah
the question before the time the space
that you need for the local computation
is it also part of this s or yes the
space needed for the computation per
machine is s okay so that's the
difference to what we had before right
before it was only the data that we will
see the way to store and not the
application space I mean before you're
considering the load
which is the amount of data divided by
this number of machines to a factor so
this is the space for machine
corresponds within the
emergency Studio
had the impression the previous told the
load was the quantity of data are
received by a machine and then it did
not account so the data used locally in
this machine during the computation ah
yes but
yes we count this as part of this so I
guess this is a slight difference
yes
generally our amount of Extra Spaces
so there is a slight difference
so this is a comparison of the models
um this is also reproduced here on this
on this board here
um so I want to emphasize that the
complexity measures that we really want
to
um minimize are the number of rounds and
the space per machine for our model
so we can have a discussion
um during our discussion uh part of this
Workshop about the differences the
similarities between the models
um but I sort of don't want to get into
this discussion here right now
um but I just want to emphasize that for
our setting we are considering total
space that's linear in the size of the
graph that you're given near linear in
the size of graph I'll do polyball
factors
so the size of a graph is defined in
terms of n the number of vertices and M
the number of edges
and what you want is we want to minimize
the space for machine
um and the number of rounds of
computation
and the number of machines you can then
calculate to be the total space divided
by the space
yes so the number of machines is
somewhat data dependent then right
because
it could just nothing would prevent you
from sending all the data to one machine
yeah and solving it there in zero times
okay so the number of machines that's
defined here is depending on the size of
the data and this is kind of like so
it's modern logarithmic right it's
something like
end to the some exponent
um
so um potentially potentially if you're
considering s to be sub linear in the
number of vertices today it's um
potentially some x squared greater than
one
and in fact we do consider as
to be sub linear is for some of the
machines and I'll specifically talk
about the routines
um but for now let's just consider these
two models to be different and we can
have a discussion later about how this
is about and how they're exactly they're
doing
um and
I just want to also mention that a lot
of our algorithms if we can
if they can work in the setting where
it's sublinear in n
most of our algorithms can also work for
larger space permission
so if it works for the sublinear setting
you can also work for larger space
machine most of our algorithms
so in terms of uh this parameter space
per machine we have three settings
so we consider what's called a strongly
sublinear memory setting so in this
setting we have this Facebook machine to
be S equals n to the Delta for some
constant Delta in zero one so this is a
this is a different Delta than what's
shown here so we have constant Delta in
um
in the range01
we also have the near linear memory
regime which is uh when the space for
machine is near linear in the number of
nodes in your input
so ignoring some poly log factors
and we also have strongly sublinear
memory in which uh your space per
machine is n to the one plus Delta for
some constant greater than zero so
normally when you want to consider a
smaller number of machines you're in a
strongly super linear memory setting
yes so one question we discussing
yes
characterize memory with respect to n
which is not your input because m is
your size viewing that's right
why does it make sense
from an algorithm point of view to use
and Azure parameter to characterize your
memory
um so others can correct me here but I
think a lot of this uh this intuition
comes from the streaming setting so from
the streaming setting you have
um semi streaming in which your memory
that you use for semi-streaming settings
in terms of end
instead of
M and that's just the definition of the
streaming setting okay so I think the
the parameter chosen here is taken with
respect to some uh some intuition from
the streaming setting
yes
into account the connectivity of the
machine
oh that's a good question um so the
connectivity of the machine is uh you
assume a fully connected communication
Network
um so I think some some others here
including Paris and Xiao have some work
on um deciding when you're uh not fully
connected it was interesting so now
we're fully communicating uh fully
connected communication
and you can send point-to-point messages
so
um I just want to emphasize again
um within each of these settings you
want to minimize the number of rounds of
communication
so specifically what the types of rounds
that we generally allow
um are all of log log and rounds or of
one round
and we want Total near linear space
um and of course
um as in the database setting we want
the memory per machine to be sublinear
in the total number of edges so the
total size of your input
and
um I will actually show you a technique
where log log n is is intuitive so I'll
actually show a bit later
um
so let me defer that question to when I
show that technique
um and for the strongly sublinear memory
um setting uh we often have Delta to be
one half
there's a variety of uh
recent work within the past four years
on graph algorithms in this specific NPC
model
um
and a lot of these Works center around
matching
um but there's a variety of other
problems there
um and within this model we have some
useful NPC Primitives that we can
perform in sublinear space specifically
near the square root of n space where n
is the size of your input here so this
is Big N not little n so n is just the
size of your input and we can do all
this in constant number rounds
um so we can solve n integers
uh we can count distinct elements
uh we can perform prefix sum so if
you're given some n integers in order
you can sum for the ice integer you can
sum every integer that came before that
and you can also do sorting
exactly
yes they're all exact
um some some have um
randomized algorithms
so now um I'll show you a technique that
gets you log longer and rounds so this
technique
um doesn't get you constant but it's a
really cool technique that uses
distributed graph algorithms in the
local distributed graph algorithm model
um which I'll Define
and this is called round compression
and the goal of this technique is to
simulate multiple rounds of an iterative
local distributed algorithm using a
single MPC round
so this essentially shows that uh that
this model has more power
um than some some distributed uh
models for some problems
so what is this local model in the
distributed setting so this local model
in the distribute setting is a fairly
old model
um where you have a synchronous
distributed algorithm where you assume
each node is a processor or computer
so instead of having a machine that can
contain multiple nodes multiple edges
you're assuming each node is itself a
processor and they communicate with
their neighbors
and the communication graph is actually
defined uh by the input graph so instead
of MPC we're assuming a fully connected
communication graph here the
communication graph is defined by the
infograph that you're given
okay
so you have some synchronous distributed
algorithm each node is trying to compute
some local value via Communications with
their neighbors
and what can you do in one single this
round of communication
uh so each node can perform the
following steps in this order
so they can perform some local
computation
after they perform a local competition
they can send a point point message to
each of their neighbors so they might
send different messages
to each of their neighbors
um some models some broadcast uh
distributed models assuming you send the
same message but here we're assuming
point-to-point messages
and then finally
um ishno receives a message from each of
his neighbors
no
no that's right so here you have a
topology for your communication Network
which is your input graph that's right
each round your limits just a single
message exchange between the layers
right yes that's right
compression for example you compress
k-ros you also assume
the number of message that can be
communicated between for example K
between neighbors yeah so when you do
round compression which I'll get into
um it's all in one machine but you can
you can still assume that it's one
message per round
um it's everything when you do round
compression you're doing on one machine
so you can you can essentially do
whatever you want because we don't
consider local computation time but if
you want a direct simulation you're
still assuming what message sent between
neighbors around
okay so this is your definition of a
local model in the distributed setting
so now let me tell you how to do round
compression using this using these
algorithms
okay so remember
now we have machines that can store more
than one node per machine so we want to
do some local simulation a part machine
of these local distributed graph
algorithms
yeah
so in this generalized procedure we pick
appropriate subgraphs of sufficiently
small size
where we send each subgraph to a single
machine
so here's an example we picked some
appropriate subgraphs and we send it to
a machine
so each subgraph goes to a single
machine
now within each of these machines we're
doing some simulation of the local
algorithm in each of these machines
so we're stimulating this local
algorithm on the inducer graph within
each of these machines
and then after doing the simulation
um the machines send the results
produced by the simulation of the local
algorithm to the other machines
okay so this is a very general
uh description of round compression so
let me show you an example
of how to do this uh round compression
on a very simplified example for a
Vertex cover
so here I'm looking at the minimum
vertex cover
and this problem is just defined on the
graph uh where each has each Edge in a
graph is covered by at least one of his
endpoints
and the minimization version of this
problem is you want to find the minimum
number of endpoints that cover every
Edge in the graph
so for this example graph I think this
is a minimum vertex cover
um for this example graph
so you can see every Edge is covered by
at least one of these two endpoints and
I I believe this is a minimum number of
vertices you pick for this for this
example
so what I'm going to show here is a very
simplified version
um of the two plus Epsilon approximate
vertex cover algorithm
um
by gaffari goliakis uh Conrad Mitsubishi
rubenfeld
um and what they actually get is uh the
approximation in near linear space
permission in all of log login rounds
um but as I said I'm going to present a
simplified version
uh and in the simplified version I'll
put some constraints on the input so
that it's easier to explain
um in a presentation
this example will be l Ed illustrating
this round compression algorithm so I'm
going to start by defining their local
algorithm that they use
so the local algorithm that they use is
based on the Primal dual method
so you can write an LP to formulate your
vertex cover problem so that's the LP on
the left that's your primal and then of
course you can formulate uh the Dual for
your primal
um and let's help either says simple
approximation scheme that gives you a
two approximation
um
using uh just solving the relaxed
version the LP for the Primal so that
gets to a true approximation via simple
rounding scheme
so let me explain
um these two LPS
so for the primal what you want is each
vertex has this variable
um X U associated with vertex U
and you want for every Edge this
variable associated with u plus this
variable associated with v is greater
than equal to one
so in the end of coral case uh each Edge
is covered by at least one of their
inputs
so in the Tool uh this is uh the
formulation for the Dual the intuitive
uh definition for the Dual
and instead of having a variable for
every node
you instead have a variable for every
Edge
and the summation
for every vertex the summation of the
edge variables
uh for each of the edges adjacent to
that vertex
is that most one
so for every vertex you have this
constraint
where the summation of your Edge
variables
uh adjacent to that vertex is almost one
just checking is it the same thing as
the edge packing problem
uh yes so this is a fractional matching
problem so you can yes
uh fractional matching
same thing I believe is equivalent
is there like an integral Gap yes
so
um for the Primal you have all nodes uh
covered up by at least one endpoint for
the Dual you have the factual matching
your local algorithm for this problem
so there's a sequential version of this
problem
um but I'll present the local version
and the local version gives you a two
plus Epsilon approximate value
uh via weak Duality so here's a local
algorithm
initially you set all these Edge
variables to be one over Delta so Delta
is defined to be the maximum degree
of any vertex in the graph
so initially you said all these uh Edge
variables to one over Delta
and then you repeat the following
procedure
um until uh you reach some stopping
condition and the stopping condition is
all the edges are frozen so I'll tell
you what Frozen means as I go through
the procedure
so let's say you're in iteration t
okay
so for iteration T you freeze a vertex
and all of its adjacent address if the
summation of uh The Edge variables for
that vertex
is greater than or equal to 1 minus two
Epsilon
you give an excellent right you're given
Epsilon Epsilon we can assume some
constant
um yeah constant in between zero one
so this is a definition of freeze
so as all all of your adjacent variables
to your vertex exceed some boundary
which is one minus two Epsilon you
freeze that vertex at all the adjacent
edges
sorry are you freezing edges or the
vertices you're freezing edges when you
freeze the vertex so when you freeze the
vertex you freeze all these adjacent
edges
yeah Edge freezing depends on the
adjacent any adjacent vertex freezing so
but you could have any facing about that
some of the adjacent edges were frozen
in some are not so you just please
yeah the freeze the one that haven't
been frozen yet that's right
that's right
um so for each active which is defined
as non-frozen Edge
um at the end of freezing
you
um increase
is uh weight by one over one minus
Epsilon
so recall we're saying Epsilon is some
constant uh in between zero one
is there an increase in the weight
they repeat this until all of the
um edges are frozen
so this is the stopping condition is on
freezing all the edges and recall we're
freezing the edges because we're
freezing vertices
stopping conditions freezing edges and
then you return the set of Frozen
vertices as your vertex cover
and what you show using weak uh Duality
that this gives you a two polyep sound
approximation
on your vertex cover
um and now you can do this in Old login
rounds
and
big base here
is one over one minus Epsilon
y e by 1 minus
uh
the fraction one over one minus Epsilon
set the new uh y of an edge to be a
scaled a version
[Music]
ah okay so um because you're freezing
when you have one minus two over
absolutely two minus one minus two
Epsilon
um you'll freeze it before it violates
the constraint thanks
so that's your local algorithm
now I'll show you how to use this uh in
round compression
okay so I making some
some very much simplifying assumptions
so the first assumption I'm making is um
you assume the maximum degree in your
input graph is O of n to the one over
nine so your maximum degree is sublinear
okay
now um the second assumption I'm making
is that you can do this easily in
constant number rounds so assume you can
do some partitioning of the graph into
some graphs of radius eight
okay so you can partition the graphs
easily into subgraphs of radius eight
and then you give the entire graph of
radius 8 to a single machine
so once
you're running the local algorithm on
each of these machines for this mini
rounds so specifically log Delta over 10
rounds and now 10 is somewhat arbitrary
but it has to be a large enough constant
on the denominator and I'll show some
calculations here
running this local algorithm so you're
doing the simulation of the local
algorithm for this simplify case you can
assume you're doing an exact simulation
of the local algorithm I just discussed
local algorithm is running just
machine
you're you're running your exact local
algorithm in the simplified version
on the subgraph that's on your machine
how about the boundary of the talk about
oh yes so boundary of software I'll
discuss
okay
um and then uh you find the new graph
after removing the Frozen vertices
in your run of the simulation
um Frozen vertices and edges so there's
two things I need to discuss here so
first uh why do we want to run this many
rounds as opposed to running arbitrary
number of large number of rounds so the
problem here exactly is the boundary
vertices
so you don't want to run too many rounds
such that each of your machines if you
have a boundary vertex and some of these
adjacent edges are on some machines and
some of its adjacent edges are other
machines you don't want the sum of all
the edge variables to exceed
um one
when you aggregate the information
across all the machines
so this is why we can't actually run
arbitrary number rounds here so we have
to run abounding number of routes
number of rounds has to be large enough
to obtain the next property though I'll
tell you about
and this has to be large enough so
that's how you can increase your radius
next time you're running this algorithm
so for this example I'll set the new
radius to 9 and I'll repeat the book
with the new radius
and you keep repeating this while
increasing the radius until you can fit
all the graph on one machine and then
you just solve it on that one machine
so after you
because steamed even the same or it also
didn't
depends the same no dependence on the on
the radius
like it's not a specific machine right
ah yes so partitioning step I'm hiding
under a simplified version that you can
assume you can do this easily this is a
big assumption big assumption
for the purposes of this presentation
you can feel a new Global graph okay and
then you repartition you repartition
using the global graph
that's right
so the global craft we do
exactly and I'm going to show
how to reduce this graph as you go so
why does this work here's a few things
so because of our assumptions
because of all these assumptions
um this part uses sublinear memory so
using radius 8 plus is assumption on the
max degree and assuming you can
partition the graph easily you use
sublinear memory here
um and here is a Crux of the of the
analysis
so he showed that running the local
algorithm in this many rounds means that
the minimum weight on any Edge becomes
Delta to the negative 0.9
so how do you how do you calculate this
so each of the load on each of the edges
you initially start with one over Delta
and each time each round you're
increasing the load by a factor of one
over one minus Epsilon
and you're running this for um this log
Delta over 10 Rounds
we can simplify how large this load gets
so this load on every Edge that remains
unfrozen so every active Edge becomes at
least Delta to the negative 0.9
and what does this mean
this means that you're doing this every
single every single time you run this
entire algorithm
so after the ithe duration of running
this entire out with almost partitioning
and running the local algorithm your
weight on each Edge after the icing
iteration becomes Delta is to negative
0.9 to the I
so your weight increases doubly
exponentially which also means your
maximum degree decreases doubly
exponentially
so your maximum degree after the ice
iteration
actually becomes one over Delta to the
negative 0.9 to the I so Delta to 0.9 to
the I after the I the iteration
and the reason for this is because if
you have a degree greater than this your
vertex will get Frozen
during that round so all the edges
adjacent to that will get Frozen
because you're
um decreasing the maximum degree W
exponentially you need old law again
rounds
thank you
great
um so this is round compression
uh and the reason why we call this round
compression because we just compressed
all of login rounds in the local model
to Old Log n PC rounds
at the sum the only exponential increase
is actually used in quite a few papers
um and the reason why we often obtain uh
old log login rounds in the MPC model
it's a lot of local models use of login
rounds
you can turn a message passing algorithm
into
because what you showed us is just one
example and it seems to be a little
brittle in terms of setting the
parameters
yes there are um so
um I believe Kershaw has a manuscript
that does this for boundary degree
graphs
so local algorithms for bounded degree
input graphs
um I believe he has a he has a
conversion for that but
um correctly if I'm wrong uh there The
Meta theorem was not for all General
graphs I believe there doesn't exist at
meta theorem for General graphs
so experience when you have skill
we're assuming unique edges unique
vertices
yes apply this on a back graph we
compress it down to two iterations
uh on the compressed graph
a path graph
um I believe it's still log log n
oh I guess for path graph you have of n
edges so you can just put it on one
machine
in Nearly New York City
yeah so when you're a number of edges is
uh close to end you can just put it on
one machine and our definition of a near
linear setting wait but you want
something
oh we don't have sublinear space uh for
for this result it's a sublinear space
given my very big assumptions
yeah so this this result
um Works in their linear space and we
actually have conditional lower bounds
based on fine grain complexity that
shows that uh if you you can't obtain a
little of logical and rounds for a sub
linear space
yeah so um these lower the bands are
fine grain so I believe it's um
assuming
um the hardness of connectivity
um in little old login rounds in NPC
yes
it holds for matching
I believe the paper also includes vertex
cover
for constant
ly so what is the exactly saying that if
you want to do
something in
very machine sub linear space in and
permission yeah you need a at least a
non-concept like
near linear Total Space
near linear Total Space also assuming us
um and there's an improvement to average
average degree
in this most recent paperless
wait but then if you have
okay
all right
um so let me quickly
go over the second technique which is
random partitional vertices so a lot of
papers do random partitional vertices so
they can actually extend
um their algorithm to the very general
setting without any of the simplifying
assumptions
um using a random partitioning of
vertices plus some other techniques so
they do a slightly different simulation
of their local album so it's not the
local algorithm I presented but it's
slightly different variation of that
okay so let me um quickly talk about
random partitioning vertices and our
favorite problem triangle County
um and I don't need to Define triangle
counting here but here's the obligator
obligatory um uh set of practical uses
for triangle counting
um
so what can we do here so uh triangle
counting you can estimate the number of
triangles to one plus Epsilon
approximation
um by randomly partitioning the vertices
in one position
so first algorithm we can consider
randomly partitioning your vertices
find it induce a graph in each machine
and then each machine counts number
triangles in the inducer graph
and then you can sum up the number of
triangles in each machine and then
return this value which is T times one
over Q one over here is a probability
um of sampling interior machines
so um using second moment method uh we
need Q to be at least
um this this expression here so let me
explain what this expression means
um in order to get a concentration about
um so this expression says Delta e is
the maximum number of triangles that are
adjacent to any Edge e
and T real is number of triangles that
you actually have in your graph
okay
um and we want to do this in near a
linear space per machine
so that means that um Q squared which is
the probability of any Edge ending up in
the machine so your Edge ends up in a
machine both of its vertices are
partitioned to that machine
so 2 squared is number of probability
any Edge ends up in the machine so
expected number of edges you'll get in
any machine that's Q squared times M you
want near linear memory so you can plug
in uh this expression for Q
squared here
um and solve for T reel
so T reel then gives you
um this bound is greater than equal to
the average degree
um I guess when your number of triangles
I share an edge is at least square root
of the average degree
so what this means is that you get a one
plus Epsilon approximation in near
linear space
when the number of triangles is at least
the average degree of your breath
um so we can actually do slightly better
than that when you increase
um the total space slightly
so our result here um we can actually
get a one plus Epsilon approximation
when uh the number of triangles is at
least square root of the average degree
okay
um and the caveat is we slightly have
worse we have slightly worse Total Space
so we have some poly logs in the total
space compared to
um exactly of n previously
and we unfortunately don't get sublinear
space
is that open problem whether we can
guess a linear space so there's no lower
bounds for triangle County here
that's an interesting problem
so I'll now discuss
um and basically the algorithm is
instead of partitioning you're just
sampling the vertices okay so each
vertex gets sampled with replacement
into a machine
into a machine with probability q and I
will actually set probability Q later so
it's not the same probability Q as
before
um is a different probability Q
okay so each vertex gets sampled into a
machine with replacement with
probability of the Q
as before we count the number of
triangles in the machine uh in the
induced sub graph of the vertices are
sampled into the machine
um and we use the total count of this
triangle as an estimator
um and we also repeat this in parallel
all of login times so with uh we repeat
this entire process
ah using copies with independent sources
of Randomness to get a concentration
down
uh using media entry
so there's a number of challenges which
we solve the first is of course the
induced sub graphs do not exceed the
space per machine
the second is how do you compute the
inducer graph in each machine when one
Edge can appear on multiple machines
or or one vertex and also one Edge can
appear in multiple machines
and
you want to of course show concentration
best
thank you you need to account for for
both challenge one and Challenge three
um and challenge two is that we're
assuming some K wise independent hash
functions for small enough K so we can
actually show this for um log n
is some poly login
um wise independent hash functions
and then finally
um each of our simulations gets some
constant probability of success
um and we use the median trick across
our log n simulations with independent
random lists together a high probability
bound
okay
um so let me let me show you the quick
proof for the lower bound on the number
of triangles
um so magically we got this uh Q I'm
using using uh our uh calculation for
getting a high probability bounds
um so just assume we have this Q for the
probability
okay so T has to be large enough that we
see at least one triangle
and so each triangle appears on a
machine with probably the Q uh cubed
times the number triangle times the
number of machines so Big M is number of
machines
it sends uh Q squared times M assuming
near linear memory
um equals this expression
so this expression is already Omega one
so we just need to show that Q times t
is omega 1.
so we already know near linear memory
this expression is Omega one we just
need to show this
okay
um so it suffices to show that t is
Omega of 1 over Q
and with a setting of Q uh we get that t
is Omega of n over s
if I assume near linear memory that is
the square root of the average degree
um and finally
um
there are a number of Nice Class notes
um that I've seen uh throughout the
years here's some nice class notes if
you want to learn more about this
particular MPC model there are others
um but here are two examples
and in terms of open questions and
future directions
um overall we want to extend this result
for Smalls up our accounting so we're
able to do this for some small subgraphs
we want but we want to have a
generalized
um
generalization of what types of sub
graphs we can do
of course we want to decrease the space
per machine usage so we want to have
some results in the sublinear memory per
machine
and maybe an easier problem in that
domain is
perhaps we can consider some sparse
grass to begin with so Sportscraft in
the sublinear memory permission setting
and that's it
um happy to take any additional
questions
[Applause]
this one
[Music]
So when you say you repeat this longer
in time this comedy do you need to do do
you really do it in log and round so can
you just do the one round
machine okay you do it in parallel so we
guarantee constant number of rounds okay
so you don't want to do synchronous or
login rounds you want to do everything
in parallel so it's just an independent
instance that you're running in parallel
with an independent Source
but yeah you get neolinear this is why
we get near linear because we have some
poly login factors because of the
repeating repeating instances of the
simulation
in the
locality assembling
um
I mean get anything in terms of uh
better results
um we have no concern that but
potentially
all right so if you get back here at two
uh so as a reminder before
yeah four questions approximately the
problem
and then like yesterday kind of break up
into jobs
reporter